foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Rosanna Lockwood up to 350 000
appointments and operations could be
canceled in what's being called the
worst industrial action in the nhs's
75-year history do junior doctors
deserve that 35 pay rise they're asking
for or is their four-day walkout an
unacceptable risk to patients lives
we'll be debating
as Joe Biden prepares to land in
Northern Ireland in the next hour I'll
be joined live by former t-shock bertia
Hearn on whether the U.S president can
succeed in keeping his the peace in
Northern Ireland
and claims the late Queen wanted both
Harry and William to do their Duty and
go to war was it fair to let Harry take
the risk of Tours in Afghanistan but not
William because of his future role as
king
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Rosanna Lockwood hello
there good evening welcome to Pierce
Morgan uncensored with me Rosanna
Lockwood Pierce still on the holiday
over there in la la land I'm with you
for the next few nights now this is what
I've been thinking about today just when
you thought winter was over a weekend of
spring Sunshine it had us all fall
didn't it but this morning we woke up to
wind rain and a four-day Junior doctor's
strike now when we look at the details
behind the headlines it is I think quite
hard not to find sympathy with them it's
an incredibly difficult job needs years
of expensive education and then they
start on wages of 14 pounds an hour is
it any wonder that so many of them are
jacking in the NHS and migrating to
sunny Australia I'm sort of half tempted
to join them when I look at the weather
today but of course it's more serious
than that and where should the
compromise be found the government says
that the calls from the BMA from the
doctors for this 35 five percent pay
rise is quite completely out of step and
it would cost us two billion pounds and
where is two billion pounds even going
to come from the international monetary
fund announcing to the world today that
the UK is on track to be the worst
performing Advanced economy this year
predicting our GDP is going to shrink by
minus 0.3 percent in 2023 over the
channel the Eurozone is going to grow by
0.8 and the US will grow by 1.6 percent
and even Russia's economy is set to
perform better than ours what are our
politicians doing while all this is
happening they're hurling insults at
each other via campaign adverts racing
each other to the bottom in the hope of
grappling power and elections a year and
a half from now
in my mind we don't have that time to
waste joining me to discuss all of this
senior consultants and lecturer Dr
pankania and former advisor to Margaret
Thatcher null Gardner thank you
gentlemen both for joining on this uh
this important issue
um I'm going to come to you first though
doctor because obviously you you've got
the medical experience here and I want
to get your sense of just uh the kind of
struggle that Junior doctors face at the
moment
it's a tremendous struggle Rosanna it is
a struggle with a unbelievable amount of
responsibility on young uh soldiers
solder shoulders and they they work so
hard and they look after our health and
well-being and this is serious training
with uh uh appraisals revalidation uh
re-licensing and a lot of responsibility
and a lot of responsibility with this is
the really important bit Rosanna it
really is and the media are not grasping
it which is this this problem did not
arise today it arose when George Osborne
started his austerity measures and has
not increased pay for health workers
nurses teachers
Etc over the last 12 years so it isn't a
pay rise it is more a restoration
restoration of the pay that should have
been over the last 12 years and they're
not asking for that pay to be reinstated
immediately it can be phased those are
the issues now when we think about where
next from this because by this point the
public in Britain have seen a wave of
strikes throughout winter and we've
gotten used to seeing the government
really not getting around the
negotiating table although there was
some progress made with some of the
transport strikes now in this side of
things we're hearing the BMA we're
hearing the doctors saying Steve Barkley
uh is not getting around the negotiating
table let's take a listen
we are ready to have discussions with
them but clearly a demand for 35 over 20
000 pounds for some Junior doctors is
not fair or reasonable and that is why
we've not been able to make progress so
far but we want to engage constructively
we recognize Junior doctors have been
under significant pressure particularly
from the pandemic and we want to work
with them to find a fair and reasonable
settlement the come to Nile Gardner on
this then when you listen to Steve
Barkley saying that but we also hear the
doctor say look we're ready to negotiate
as well where's the missing piece here
well thank you very much for having me
on the show uh today and without a doubt
of course student doctors do work
incredibly uh hard uh and I think there
is a lot of sympathy for junior doctors
however uh the idea of going on strike
for several days putting lies at risk I
think fundamentally goes against
everything that doctors are supposed to
stand for and this is completely the
wrong strategy and and tactic and I I do
fear that if if the government actually
makes concessions uh to thee to the
unions here
this will just be I think the beginning
of more and more concessions uh being
made to the unions here and and I think
that this idea of a 35 percent
um pay rise it's absolutely insane uh
this this is completely unrealistic uh
this is uh basically public money we're
talking about here uh and I I think it's
just not realistic be asking for 35 pay
rise this also on the scores I think
many of the fundamental flaws within the
National Health Service uh this is a uh
I think in many respects a very outdated
Healthcare uh system it's almost unique
in in Europe uh it is I think way behind
the times uh and and I think that it is
really not able to cope with the
circumstances of the 21st uh Century uh
and of course I I think the United
Kingdom has to move more and more
further down the path towards private a
healthcare to provide a better service
overall for for British uh patients
I want to come back to the idea of the
future but Dr Dr bankalia coming to you
because also I want to hear what you've
got to say but also is it insane to be
asking for 35 pay rise
and no of course it isn't and I said it
again and I will repeat it this is not a
pay rise this is a restoration of what
pay cuts they've had over the last 12
years furthermore I add the MPS have had
a pay increase not to pay uh restoration
a pay increase furthermore right
compared to comparable European Union
countries the United Kingdom contributes
a lot less in its health care for its
people considering it is a G7 Rich
affluent Nation furthermore one more
very important Point Rosanna you said
where are we going to find the two
million of which that two million one
million will go back in taxes anyway
just a second so
list trust and her crazy uh Chancellor
quasi-cotang lost the country
65 billion pounds which the bank of
England had to find and fund and so the
G7 country that we are we have got the
money if we choose to spend it in the
right way in the right place tax the
other sectors which have got a lot more
income for example the fuel companies
they are making a lot of money and the
government is reluctant to tax them it
is a compelling argument don't you think
Nile that the hardest working health
care workers in our society should get
rewarded when you've got people in
financial services now not saying tax
everyone to the hill windfall taxes for
the lot but when you stand back and look
at a junior doctor getting paid 14
pounds an hour and a two years qualified
after all of that education and then you
see Bankers you see fuel Executives you
see all sorts of Industry Executives
getting so much more than that and
Junior doctors have had a pay cut by
over about a quarter in the last 15
years I mean can you hear what Dr
pankale is coming from
doctors don't have an automatic right to
higher salaries so that's that's not the
reality here and what is crazy actually
uh is the idea of doctors uh going on
strike and putting lives at risk this is
very dangerous actually it's callous and
it's heartless we should never see this
actually in a civilized society this
sounds completely the wrong uh the wrong
signal and this idea there's some
endless pot of of public money uh this
is just just ludicrous socialist of
course like like the idea of spending
other people's money as my former boss
Margaret Thatcher used to say but there
are limits to the amount of public money
uh that can be that can be spent uh
doctors I do not think are in a position
to be requesting a 35 uh pay Rises
completely it's a restaurant
and they they should be working they
should be working with the heart of of
Public Service here uh and they're not
in the in the in the field of medicine
really for the their own financial
interest of course they're in the field
of medicine to serve the public to save
lives going on strike is going to cost
lies it's fundamentally dangerous it's
unacceptable it might be for doctors be
going on strike
a dangerous move here I can't speak for
the doctor today but calling them callus
and heartless when they are doing the
work that they're doing for so little is
a challenging concept I just want to ask
you I'll come back to you um Dr bankalia
shortly if I want to ask you now if you
believe so much in Market forces can you
understand why junior doctors are
migrating somewhere like Australia or if
they can other countries as well where
they get treated better and they get
paid better
yeah sure I mean you know they have
every right to go and work in the public
sector to go and work abroad but at the
end of the day there are public servants
paid for by by the British public here
and the public expects a minimum level
of service they can provide that when
they're going on strike and I think it's
fundamentally incompatible this idea of
striking with actually being a being a
doctor on the front line providing vital
life-saving a service there here so I
think it's fundamentally wrong and I
think it's absolutely unacceptable just
just as it would be wrong for police
officers to go on strike or the military
to go on strike it's the same for
doctors they are vital in terms of
saving lives we have seen plenty of
other services
you know
and you know talk to us of course they
are paid from the public purse here they
have no right to sort of astronomical uh
a pay rise uh MPS are also paid from the
public pocket and plenty of other
services too
um I would argue one Birmingham Doctor
Gina doctor shared his pay slip today
after taxes and the rest of its uh
student loans he was there for 1 823
pounds a month that's a two years
qualified Junior doctor when you
consider how much it costs to rent a
house a cost of living crisis as well
don't they deserve more now
well you know doctor should be
campaigning for lower taxes actually
frankly uh let's reduce uh the size of
the tax burden Advance economic freedom
raise prosperity and wealth for everyone
actually that's that's by far the best
solution here instead of actually going
on
um
and it's going to alienate the the
public massively I think that that's the
worst possible way to gain public
support by getting on strike Dr pankalia
should they doctors instead be focusing
on lowering taxes
no certainly not we would want uh lower
taxes or the less well-off the trouble
is this country this government has gone
on to give tax breaks the current
Chancellor of the exchequer gave a huge
tax break to the rich who can afford to
top up their pensions above the million
pound cap and then they're telling us
they have the goal to tell us that
um we are cutting taxes you are not
cutting taxes you're cutting taxes for
the rich the already rich if you were if
you were to tax the oil companies the
Starbucks of this world the Amazons of
this world you would find the money to
pay for the teachers the doctors the
nurses the education people you would
the issu the issue is you do not want to
do that
thank you both very much for joining us
this evening giving us your insights
next tonight as President Biden prepares
to land in Belfast will he really be
able to help keep the peace in Northern
Ireland we'll be discussing that next
foreign
[Music]
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book frankly it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
welcome back now huge Security operation
is already in place in Belfast for the
visit of U.S President Joe Biden he's
going to arrive in Northern Ireland this
evening to Mark the 25th anniversary of
the signing of the Good Friday peace
agreement
proud of his Irish Roots he's always
praised what politicians did to secure
peace back in 1998 but the visit is
overshadowed by a little bit of unrest
in the country you could say that with
the Democratic unionist party continuing
to boycott the Northern Ireland
government and with petrol bombs thrown
at offices during an illegal Republican
parade over the weekend pipe bombs found
today police are on high alert for this
presidential visit so is the Good Friday
agreement under threat joining me now is
the former t-shock of Ireland Bertie
Ahern Mr Ahern it's a real pleasure to
speak to you on a day like this on a
time like this let's just start by
remembering the good Friday agreement
you were T Shock at the time talk to us
about your abiding memory of that time
that agreement that you said was a new
beginning for Northern Ireland for the
island of Ireland and for these islands
yeah I think wasn't at the time it was
bringing together nationalists
um and Republicans unionists and
Loyalists and we're the two governments
so it was you know there were eight
parties the two governments uh chaired
by
um Senator Mitchell and it it certainly
you know brought an end to 30 years of
violence that thankfully there's been
there's been some killings and and some
uh bad events you know since Oma but by
and large it's been very very peaceful
um last night to some young people on
the streets but obviously people behind
them giving them petrol bumps but
talking to some of the people there
today it were about 20 of them but it
it's um it's been peaceful politically
it hasn't so been so easy I think Tony
Blair and I you know we had an inclusive
process of bringing all the parties
together even those that had been
previously associated with violence
um and we dealt with a lot of the big
issues at the time but unfortunately and
the one that is applying to me is the
fact that the institutions of the
agreement the assembly the executive
north south bodies have not been working
very well so that's where I think Rishi
sunak and the Windsor agreement
hopefully will bring a conclusion to
that standoff and there might be a few
little bits left but hopefully on the
other side of the local elections we
might be able to sort that out and U.S
president Biden of course visiting this
evening what hopes you have for that
visit
well you know my I'm to be honest I'm
very sad that he wasn't uh addressing
the um storming because of storm and had
been up and running I think he would
have been there that would have been a
greater occasion for them for the people
who were elected 15 months ago it's a
lost opportunity they would have been
seen across the world he would have an
opportunity again I think to recommit uh
to further Investments to help those
people who who need it in different
areas at the North who haven't benefited
over the years anyway that opportunity
is blown let's be I have to be pranked
about it
um but I'm sure the educational the also
University he goes to tomorrow is a
tremendous new facility at the heart of
Belfast
um the party leaders would be there
that's a good occasion but I think the
the trip to Belfast and to Northern
Ireland generally would have been far
better if the institution institutions
had been functioning uh you already
mentioned the um the young people that
were out on the streets this weekend the
dissidents the violence that there was
you've already mentioned of course that
there has been some over the years I
want to mention the young Factor here
because during the troubles during that
three decade period it was a huge
proportion it was around a quarter I
think of the deaths from the conflicts
were people between the ages of 18 and
23 you're now seeing young people still
on the streets these disadencies young
people why then is it so important that
young Generations understand the
troubles
well I think they the problem always has
been in the north right back from the
time I was in school in the 60s that
Pender was a vacuum in the political
position when when the politicians
didn't fill the center ground and be
seen to be doing their their work uh in
the assembly that tended then to drift
out to the streets and that's there's
always a day it's not happening really
now I mean there's a handful of them and
that's always a danger you don't need
too many to to cause trouble or to give
bad camera shots around the world and
that's what they're doing is that
themselves they're affecting but they're
obviously people behind them who you
know never agreed with the agreement and
unfortunately there are some of those
elements that you know continually rise
their head whenever they get an
opportunity but I I think overall if the
politicians were back uh dealing with
the issues of the day dealing with the
problems for the people of Northern
Ireland and that that would Wane very
quickly so it is very much about the
current political system now sooner uh
the Windsor framework it held up but
there were concerns there about the
impact that post-brexit trade
Arrangements would have on the Good
Friday agreement
um what stood out to me when I've been
sort of looking at your words about the
Good Friday agreement over the last few
days is that you said that when you all
sat around the negotiating table your
multi-parties you could have predicted a
lot of things but you didn't predict
brexit just how much did brexit worry
you
yeah brexit was a disaster to to be
frank
um for seven years it's created
difficulties and the real problem
Rosanna is that is that it brought up
issues that we had long settled uh
people had stopped talking about the
Border people had stopped talking about
possums posts and checkpoints is it gone
out of the everyday language it had gone
out of the political arguments even uh
brexit brought all that back again it
brought back the issues about Brenda
would be a border poll would be
triggered from The Pride agreement and
it was just totally unhelpful now I have
to say I I'm not going to quote anything
I said myself at the time of brexit but
John Major Antonio Blair both spoke
openly and frankly
um that if brexit did happen that this
was this would occur and they were 100
right
um but anyway you know with seven years
at that I think we're seeing like has
genuinely tried very hard since last
October to find a solution to that and I
certainly appreciate the efforts he's
put in I think most people in the island
of Ireland and the dup feel that
everything isn't yet achieved
um rather than giving out about that
position I think maybe we should try and
see if there's some other piece that
needs to be put in place to try to
rectify that well I suppose yeah it's
just an unbelievably relevant
conversation at the moment isn't it
separatism unions reunifications exits I
just want to get your view Mr ahead on
the Scottish independence the the
prospect of that the idea of it what
does it look like through your lens
well I I think certainly was from from
her position in Ireland it it I believe
it would be a bad idea to have a
referendum here until two things happen
one that the institutions of the pride
agreement are up and running and two
that should prepare the case and now we
have neither of those at the moment so
there will be a referendum someday
because it's provided for the good Pride
agreement and it is it was a commitment
that was given uh that we if we agreed
consent
um and the only changes can be made
constitutionally are on the basis of the
consent to the people in Northern
Ireland but that people have an
aspiration for either a union or unity
and that's the balance that Tony Blair
and I struck in a good Pride agreement
is government
um if you were talking about a year ago
I would say probably the argument for
another Scottish referendum looks strong
and they had to convince the British
government now it seems to have drifted
back down the agenda a lot how different
do you think the negotiations would have
been in a time like now whether social
media where there is so much opinion
where it's very easy to give opinion
well I think it'd be impossible I'm not
a big number of social media my age will
give that away I suppose but I I think
it you know we we had
um aged at eight parties uh two
governments probably on the final week
with several hundreds of people in
Castle buildings because people brought
in all their politicians that brought in
their Executives and negotiating teams
are already there so at one at any stage
it could have two or three 400 maybe I
don't know how many was in the building
but it would have been very hard to keep
control and to keep it central rise
negotiation as we did between George
Mitch and Tony Blair and and myself and
you know my team was Liz O'Donnell
um David Andrews and a small team of
officials so Antonio Blair was the same
I think it'd be very hard to control
that situation in the age of social
media social media yeah I think I quite
agree with you that look we're
negotiating The Good Friday agreement
it's seeing that you focused a lot more
on what people were for rather than what
they were against at least in some
strands of it now when it was signed it
was held up as potentially a model for
other International conflicts to kind of
uh cut and paste that could be used
elsewhere but it doesn't seem to have
translated to other regions are you
disappointed by that
well I think there's not a week goes by
and certainly not a month that goes by
that there's not and political parties
negotiating teams and governments or
other NGO bodies that come to Northern
and from all over the world
um and they explore you know what
happens you know what we did not only in
1998 but what we did in the years after
right up to 2007 when it's genuinely
felt that we we got kind of got things
reasonably stable and it took us that
long so my message always to these
delegations I I don't meet all of them
but I made some of them is that these
things aren't easy and the negotiations
you need certain ingredients one you
need that people are not prepared just
to have the status quo if people like
the status quo and they don't mind
violence and they're not prepared to
move away from it then it's very hard to
convince them I think the second thing
is you have to put yourself in the shoes
of the other side you have to understand
what are are the issues of the people
who were opposed to and I think you have
to be prepared to negotiate fairly and
try and get balances and compromises if
you want to just force your own way uh
true that seems to for my I'm not an
expert in the Middle East but I look at
the Middle East it looks as if people
just want their own way and they force
it through by the by mics and and by
physical Force well you're never going
to find Solutions if you follow those
kind of ingredients in the conflict I
think that's some advice that could be
used in so many places just want to end
by asking you do you have faith in
humanity
um I I do and you know and sometimes
those then you have to go around the
mulberry bush you know that mulberry
bush they've been talking about for
hundreds of years and I think sometimes
you have to go around it a few times
before you get people to uh to finally
compromise but you know it's better than
violence the more big voices are safe
from pushing it's absolutely better than
virus Bertie I heard it's been an honor
to speak to you on a day like this
thanks so much
thank you very much
well coming up next should Prince
William have gone to War as spare Prince
Harry was allowed to go to Afghanistan
but the risk was deemed too great for
William because of his future role as
king we'll be discussing that next
foreign
[Music]
pop the kettle on this is the royalty
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book frankly it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
foreign
the late Queen Elizabeth wanted both
Prince William and Prince Harry to do
their Duty and fight alongside British
forces in Afghanistan the former head of
the army General Sir Mike Jackson has
told documentary that the queen told him
her wishes but it was deemed too risky
for the heir to the throne to be
deployed now the risk was deemed
acceptable for Harry in his recent
Memoir spare you might remember us
talking about this the Duke of Sussex
who undertook two tours to Afghanistan
angered many by claiming he'd killed 25
Taliban soldiers and described them as
chess pieces removed from the board
I could always say precisely how many
enemy combatants I killed
and I felt it vital never to shy away
from that number
among the many things I learned in the
Army accountability was near the top of
the list
so
my number
25 they were chess pieces removed from
the board
bads taken away before they could kill
Goods
so to discuss all of this and please say
join in the studio by talk TV Royal
editor Sarah at Houston hi Sarah and
director of the British horses
Foundation Mark Cann joining us down the
line uh thanks to both of you good
evening lots to talk about here Sarah
let's come to you first now I mean in
and of itself this Revelation
interesting because it was uh given to
uh this person in uh confidence I
believe yes this is a conversation that
General Smite Jackson the former Chief
the general staff head of the British
army had with the queen and he's
revealed the details of it in a
documentary now normally an audience
with the queen would be entirely private
he says he knows it's a breach of
protocol but in this one instance he was
prepared to go there and he said the
queen said my grandsons have taken my
Shilling therefore they must do their
Duty she wanted to see Prince William
and Prince Harry fight in Afghanistan
Duty the watchword for the queen very
much the way in which she lived her life
she was across all the intelligence she
knew the risks she was clear that
William should go and fight in
Afghanistan down two should he say wish
but ultimately it was decided that those
risks were too great I can't tell if I
go back to mark do do you know what she
means the lake Queen bite it's taken my
Shilling well as commander-in-chief she
was effectively paying their salaries
and their their military salary so she's
saying that you know they were doing the
job they were being paid for that job
and therefore you do what is required of
you in the job and I think that is what
William felt about it as well he gave an
interview back in 2010 when he said you
know if you're going to do this job and
ultimately he was going to be
commander-in-chief one day you've got to
walk the walk and you you want to do
this uh role it's certainly what Harry
felt but for William given his position
as heir to the throne it was considered
far too risky for him well talk of
walking the wall let's go over to Mark
cam from the British forces point of
view mark it was this and we're not
asking you obviously to pass judgment on
The Late Queens decision making or
anybody in the royal family but from a
military point of view can you see the
rationale behind it
oh certainly uh I think many great minds
agonized over the decision at the time
uh in fact I know they did I think
ultimately it wasn't
um any one person's sort of wish that
was the major concern the major concern
was was the risk to others around in
this case William and and this war was a
very different one to previous Wars um
and therefore it was it would be much
harder to hide him much harder to hide
him actually in theater and also much
harder to hide the fact that he had gone
back here in the UK and because even
that was a problem
um later with Harry but I think I think
it would be much more obvious that he
was he was not in the country and
therefore I think people would have
quickly put two and two together so
um I I think they had no choice
um I don't know uh Prince William was
very irritated and frustrated by it but
I think um at the end of the day it was
the right decision yes sir we have
actually inside sites of from William of
what he might have felt as we can't read
Prince William's mind
um but he did share his feelings yeah he
talked about it
um in 2010 I think it was when he was
joining the RAF search and rescue and he
was asked and he said he still hoped
even at that point that he might one day
be able to serve in Afghanistan he said
he understood there was slightly valid
arguments he described it as to why he
shouldn't but he thought that they were
over hyped and he said he had Hope and
Faith and a determination to get out
there as we know it didn't happen for
him Harry was able to serve two tours of
Duty in Afghanistan but as you were
hearing from Mark there it would have
been very obvious that William wasn't in
the country there was a media blackout
when Harry was first deployed but that
was breached by Foreign broadcasters he
had to be brought back home and it's not
just about the risk to the individual to
William it's also the risk that they
might bring to others around them yeah
that point that Mark was making about
the security of people around them I
want to come back to you and just ask a
little bit about the practicalities of
Royals going to war zones because are
they exposed to exactly the same dangers
the same risks the same shocks the same
trauma some would argue as every other
yes Audi every other soldier on the
field
yes and they and they have been
historically
um you know throughout the ages in fact
there's there's nothing unusual in fact
in fact it's it was it was positively
um encouraged in order to to to to sort
of take up the leadership role they have
by dint of birth
um the the problem
um so I think that you would have been
able to do
um everything you know that was required
and I know Williams you know Williams
view was very much that you know if if
he was serving in a unit that was tasked
to go then he was part of that unit and
he should go a regiment um to be more
precise but in this case the the nature
of the war I mean it had a had a very
strong terrorist undercurrent to the to
the whole conflict as well
um would just just I think made it
impossible and and would have put others
um definitely others lives at greater
risk and ultimately had he been gone for
big captured or something like that then
I mean that that would have you know
deeply compromised the the whole
Endeavor I hear the point about you know
Royals have been um riding into war
throughout history don't test my history
but you know somebody on Horseback
certainly but that was a different time
there wasn't social media there wasn't
Paparazzi photographers there wasn't
Memoirs um sure there's security risk is
much higher
yeah I think so uh in this case and also
this was a very cyclical conflict I mean
you know something like the Falklands
which prince Andrew did I mean it was
pretty binary you know there was sort of
yes you know us us and them there was a
sort of line you know we we came ashore
and we're pushing them back this this
was this was a conflict that was raging
sort of 360 Degrees around
um certain bases so much more tricky uh
kind of conflict uh all together uh and
and you know that was an added
complication to it and uh Sarah coming
to you on the Memoirs point because as
Mark was laying out the tricky conflict
it's politically uh tricky to talk about
Afghanistan for many people these days
in and of itself and then Prince Harry
writes spare where he talks about having
uh and his word sort of taken out 25
Taliban fighters chess pieces uh with
that in mind not saying William would
have done the same but does it make
sense to withdraw to keep about such
public figures away from war zones well
I I think this plays into Prince Harry's
narrative about being the spare there's
a big difference between Prince Harry
and Prince William who is one gate day
going to be king
if the decision was made that William
was too valuable to go it was too
difficult to send him but the risk was
deemed acceptable for Harry you can see
why Harry is saying well okay well I'm
I'm dispensable and he's not but I also
think you can look at this from the
other way because Harry has talked in
his book and in his interviews about the
fact that his brother and his father are
trapped by their responsibilities within
the royal family William didn't get to
do what he wanted to do he didn't get to
go and serve in Afghanistan Harry did he
got to go out there twice and it is one
of the most important and significant
parts of his life just look at what he's
gone on to do afterwards with the
Invictus games for example it is where
he said he got to feel like Harry an
ordinary person were he in that more uh
were he in his brother's position he
wouldn't have had that opportunity there
is certainly that argument that he did
in fact have more freedom than William
in this Mo you wanted to add something
there but also I'm interested go on
yeah no come on to the other point but I
I I'm not just sure in and of itself it
was actually the risks of William's own
life that was the major consideration
here
um I I think ultimately it was that he
would have been a considered a an even
higher price Target
um than his other than his brother
um and also that that attention would
have would have drawn you know greater
risk to those serving with him
um that them was acceptable uh so I I'm
not sure it was it was the the danger
per se to William's own life that people
were really taking into account I think
there were other more strategic factors
at play and also the very realistic
issue is that if your son got blown up
because you were so heavily targeted
should Williams position have been
compromised you wouldn't have thanked
anyone for sending him out there
um so we understand of course the
soldiers fight for Queen and Country but
as you point out there that it puts them
in a very precarious and targeted
position if there is a role in their
regimen
and and no one wants to draw a fire on
themselves you know if they can possibly
avoid it so yeah yeah I mean you don't
certainly don't want to go to war with a
magnet
um but um which I think you know I think
it was a very difficult decision I mean
to your other point is to um yes I think
Carrie was free to write about it he's
not the first to do it I mean whether
it's something everyone who served would
or wouldn't do I don't know but I mean
plenty of people have have documented
their wartime experience um and it has a
certain Fascination for the public and
if you're a high profile figure that
like Harry I can see why
um
he put it in the book and indeed was
probably encouraged to put it in the
book and just quickly uh Mark if you
don't mind give us a sense um from the
serving point of view the frustration
that somebody like William might have
felt about not being able to go and
fulfill what he might have felt was his
purpose
oh huge Rosanna and and I think very
irritatingly I think the sort of humor
that would have surrounded him from his
you know his uh his friends and comrades
and you know who he served with and
everything else
um I think he was deeply frustrated I
mean it was you know when you're serving
and you're a young officer especially
you know that that was the fight of the
day and you want to be part of it I mean
that's what you've you've you've signed
up for you definitely don't want to be
seen to not be one want to be part of it
um and all the nerves and you know
considerations that go into it and
everything else but ultimately everybody
who serves wants to be part of the
whatever the punch-up is of the day
because that's what the the people
who've elected the government who made
the decision and and the queen demands
of you and that's that's the that's the
contract you've made when you um marched
off the square at Santa sort of marched
Off The Square you know Catherine or
wherever so
um yeah it would have been deeply
frustrating you know even if he
understood and I think he did the
reasons behind it and I think he would
have thought that you know I I know
myself I mean I was going to um the Iraq
first Iraq war and I I managed to do a
double Summit on a Land Rover break my
collarbone about three days before we
deployed and I was Furious yeah I mean
it just you know it was very frustrating
so I felt for him it's a hard one for
people not in the services to get their
head around but I think you've uh you've
described it to us very well there mark
can Sarah Houston in the studio as well
thank you both very much for your
insights coming next tonight here on
Piers morganland since it is labor in
the gutter with their new adverts
attacking the Prime Minister we'll be
debating that next
foreign
[Music]
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book apparently it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
well coming up on the talk shock
Revelations from the palace is a top
General claims the late Queen Wanted
Prince William to join the war in
Afghanistan and meanwhile Furious MPS
kick up a right Royal fuss over being
denied plus ones to the king's
coronation and we're being told to keep
calm and stay out of Harm's Way as
Junior doctors walk out for four days of
strike action all of that and much more
at nine
[Music]
welcome back to Pierce Morgan uncensored
with me Rosanna Lockwood standing in for
peers now let's get to some hot topics
with our panel in the studio talk TV
contributor Esther Krakow and political
journalist Ava Santina thank you both
looking gorgeous uh chess pieces this
evening
I won't say the forces of Good and Evil
I'll let the audience who make their
minds up on that one but let's talk
about some of the issues especially
they've boiled over from the weekend and
the political adverts one now we've got
these to show to our viewers as well
these are Labor's adverts that have been
shared online they're going to be shared
elsewhere as well newspapers and all
sorts accusing Rishi sunak of the
following do you think it's rise to
raise taxes for working people when your
family benefited from a tax loophole
sunak does do you think adults convicted
of sexually assaulting children should
go to prison Rishi sunak doesn't and do
you think thieves should be punished
Richie Sue neck doesn't
look it political Communications
campaigning it's been going on since the
dawn of time what has stood out about
Labor's campaign in this sense is the
directness of it some would say um the
savagery of it
um coming to First Ava do you think it
was right for labor to take this
position do you know I actually don't
mind the tax loophole accusation I think
that's totally fair but the sexual the
sexual assault yeah poster which came up
that came out on Friday that was on the
Lord's Day on Good Friday and it really
took me aback and you know social media
was a wash with disgust at this advert
and labor instead of you know rolling
back and you know reassessing and going
maybe this is a little bit much
especially as kirst armor took a real
strong dislike to Boris Johnson throwing
that jive to him last year about Jimmy
Savile I don't know if we remember that
you think that which I said was unfair
yeah it was unfair but you'd think maybe
he wouldn't throw the same sort of jibe
at the current prime minister well if
he's not in charge of this he's not I
mean the person running their social
media is some 20 something year old very
enthusiastic very politically charged
person who's very unfamiliar with the
ways of the world I do think it's gonna
backfire for two reasons one is gutter
politics right and you know the Tories
do it as well I'm not saying the
complete innocence of it but you want to
rise above that noise but also it's also
Incorrect and quite it makes it makes me
think that they don't respect their
their base and I actually think they
think their base are quite stupid like
to make the argument about the tax
loopholes that's fine but they're like
foghorns they just make noise okay what
are you going to do about it it's not
like the labor party is going to reduce
taxes if you're going to say that oh is
it fair that you know they got a tax
loophole when the working class okay
you're going to reduce taxes for the
working class then no then be quiet yeah
I got to see some policy exactly there's
some care stoma what has been
fascinating is seeing as you said that
the labor party not backing down there
were calls on social media for them to
delete these adverts they didn't we
didn't hear much from the labor party
over the weekend a few back benchers
coming out and saying they were
horrified they didn't like the adverts
it didn't really seem to matter it seems
that labor is going to stick into this
position do you really think as to that
it's some 20 year old that's interesting
well I mean it's it's Foghorn policy
right there's no actual policy behind it
they're just making noise then B minor
and just honking again
is the only way to fight fire though
with fire if they're gonna beat yeah no
I think it's really unhealthy actually
and you know care not winding back and
not reassessing is showing us the sort
of politician that he's going to be and
he is looking like he's going to be a
Boris Johnson he's going to say don't
provide people with an alternative
vision of Britain to buy into and this
is what they have never learned they
have never left I mean listen golden
brown and Tony Blair still alive they're
still you know in the 60s and 70s
they're still you know political
resources that they could tap into how
did you do it it's not you know with the
gutter politics like this it's to
provide British people with an
alternative Vision that they can buy
into and the labor party have not done
that it's very far from New labor as you
point out there that that feeling you
know as as we're marking this kind of um
25 years since the Good Friday agreement
we're Hawks back to that time where
there was hope and then where people
were provided with a vision and we're
just not seeing that Vision being laid
out by either party I'd argue at the
moment well no we haven't seen anything
at all I mean curious armor should be
coming out of the box right now he
should be telling us how is he going to
make it affordable for Brits to live
here and Thrive here he should be at the
helm of housing policy and he should be
talking about strikes and how he would
bring you know negotiations to the table
but instead we're just seeing attack
politics what's the point well he's lost
three people around this table clearly
not that I'm saying he ever had them in
the first place wouldn't make that
assumption but certainly those gutter
politics hasn't won this evening um look
let's move on and talk about some
international news from the weekend as
well fascinating on this the Dalai Lama
I didn't think we'd be talking about
this when I woke up and saw this video
being shared on Twitter I couldn't
really believe what we what we were
discussing let's take a look
thank you
and Son my tongue
it's it's a pretty difficult watch isn't
it that is the Dalai Lama the spiritual
leader of um Tibetan Buddhism there
asking a young boy to suck his tongue
getting him on the lips uh this was
actually at a ceremony quite some time
ago but the videos only sort of gone
public now and it has forced the Dalai
Lama and his team to make an apology
this is the apology a video clip has
been circulating that shows a recent
meeting when a young boy asked his
Holiness to Dalai Lama if he could give
him a hug his Holiness wishes to
apologize to the boy and his family as
well as his many friends across the
world for the hurt his words may have
caused his Holiness often teases people
he meets in an innocent and playful way
even in public and before cameras he
regrets the incident that is the
official apology come to both of you how
you felt watching that because I mean
from it's just disappointing
um when you see somebody that stature I
think we like to think some people are
pure
um not saying it wasn't pure but it's
certainly uncomfortable Esther I mean
it's
almost
I don't even know how to describe it
without getting sued so I'll just say
this back in the day people would uh
people that would work having these
sorts of interactions with young boys
would vanish Into The Ether um
regardless of kind of your religious uh
leanings should I say
um but I know that he's going to come
back is going to still be a public
figure regardless of this video and I
think we should be asking questions one
should people that you know take up
occupations where they're affected their
sexuality and their sexual desires are
repressed they they remain celibate they
never get married I think you should ask
serious questions why there are always
instances of abuse that happen in in
those kind of communities but also
should people that have been caught on
camera effectively engaging in a very
sexually inappropriate act with a young
person should they ever be able to come
back into public life that's a very
negative message to send out that these
people still have a place in in public
life and to be respected Ava do you
think the apology uh undid the ACT no I
think for me it's a sign of respect that
poor boy is sort of being forced into
doing this act with him it just makes me
really uncomfortable and actually makes
me quite reminiscent growing up Catholic
with your priest you'd always think like
a religious figure is really pure and is
out there to look after you wouldn't
hurt you I think this poor boy went in
there not really knowing how to act it's
awful to want it is very uncomfortable
look we were good around elf the show
with something a little lighter to talk
about Taylor Swift's boyfriend is it the
worst job in Show Business given that
that's a handbrake term for you isn't it
given that she has just broken up with a
boyfriend of six years and she tends to
write songs about her exes uh we did
have some songs to play You're
unfortunately not going to have time to
get to them for you that is it from ever
since 19 that's it from Esther kraku
that's it from me just for this evening
gonna be back in this chair tomorrow
maybe we'll pay you some Taylor Swift
then whatever you're up to then make
sure it is uncensored good night
[Music]
all right
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book frankly it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
which will